what's going on there reject nation we're gonna
watch today disney's tangled yeah this has been
requested ever since i covered in kanto i
know a lot of people are like greg don't you
normally have a lady guest with you well all the
ladies have seen it except john that's right man
the sexiest lady of them all hasn't seen it i'm
gonna be completely honest with you guys i don't
know if i've seen this i have i have no idea if
i've actually seen some of it or any of it i try
to recall and i'm like i don't know anything
so i'm going to assume that this is my first
time watching this movie to be totally honest uh
but yeah here we are uh if you guys can leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated subscribe and
click that notification bell to get notified when
we get another reaction up here on the channel
that you might enjoy full length reaction watch
along where you sync up with your own copy
or over at our patreon page thank you to all
become super sexy rejects by checking out all
we got to offer got plenty of things over there
and thanks to the team at prepper for helping us
edit down these reaction highlights lastly thank
you to storyblocks for sponsoring this video
let's see what's the big hype about this film
this is the story of a girl named rapunzel once
upon a time a single drop of sunlight fell from
the heavens it had the ability to heal the
sick and injured oh you see that old woman
over there you might want to remember her
she's hot check hot old lady and the queen
well she was about to have a baby but she got
sick she was running out of time and that's when
people usually start to look for a miracle or in
this case a magic golden flower you see instead
of sharing the sun's gift this woman mother
gothel hoarded its healing power and used it
to keep herself young for hundreds of years mother
gothel all she had to do was sing a special song
bring back what once was mine all right you
get the gist she sings to which she turns
young creepy right she is a hot old lady
so conflicted right now the magic of the
golden flower healed the queen a healthy baby
girl a princess was born beautiful golden hair
i'll give you a hint that's rapunzel
it's not a hint that's the answer
oh
stole the child and just like that gone
so you can't cut any of her hair in a hidden
tower gothel raised the child as her own
i had a horror movie based off of something
like this but the walls of that tower could
not hide everything each year on her
birthday the king and queen released
thousands of lanterns into the sky never seen
a terrifying concept set up so sweetly before
let me suck on your life for us
but it's fun i'm gonna kidnap you
well i guess pascal's not hiding out here
7 am the usual morning line up start on the chores
and sweep to the floor's all clear yeah yeah
oh
you're actually really productive
man yeah you got everything you
need here why do you ever want to leave
you're getting a lot done be a shutdown
oh she thinks it's just some like magical thing
wow i could get used to a view like
this come on hold on i'm used to it
hay fever yeah huh
what wait bad thief this is a very big day
pascal finally gonna do it i'm gonna ask her
i'm not getting any younger down here coming
mother and i i would like to be right now
i feel like that would hurt her still how you
managed to do that every single day without fail
it looks absolutely exhausting darling oh it's
nothing then i don't know why it takes so long
you are a great mother figure it's my birthday
i distinctly remember your birthday was last year
i want to see the floating lights you know why we
stay up in this tower to keep you safe and sound
yeah guess i always knew this day was coming
i knew that soon you'd want to leave the mast
soon but not yet trust me pet mother knows
this yeah mother knows best one way or another
something will go wrong i swear poison ivy
quicksand cannibals and snakes off the plane yes
then with pointy teeth and stop no more
you'll just upset me mother's right here
skip the drama stay
get that grit plus i believe getting kind of
chubby yikes you're fat rapunzel don't ever
ask to leave this tower yes mother
i love you very much dear clearly
i'll see you in a bit my flower i'll be here
i don't know the rapunzel story i know the very
very basics she's so cruel no no no no no this is
bad this is very very bad this is really bad
they just can't get my nose right who cares
well it's easy for you to say you guys
look amazing the stabbington brothers
fred and george stabbington okay give me a boost
and i'll pull you up give us the satchel first
what give me the whip i'll throw you the idol i
can't believe that after all we've been through
together you don't trust me i i don't even trust
you i don't even know you and i don't trust you
now help us up pretty boy sorry my hands are
full what that's why they don't trust you yeah
retrieve that satchel in any course sir
seemed like you were better off at the dead end
yeah you already jumped right into the lights
nice work man come on fleabag forward
no no huh
oh my god
yo
this is an incredibly well trained horse
that horse can withstand anything yeah
sharp on your feet horse on your hooves
someone turning 18 in there
i smell a birthday party
alone at last
you can't go to the outside
the outside's coming to you
imagine if it was one of the stabbington
brothers you have the same reaction
double tap i like your style rapunzel
oh those are gonna turn purple and fall off so
i get it it's about the cycle of abuse repeating
itself she's getting kidnapped taking hostas now
she does it to someone else yeah she's recreating
it
like a glass slipper have a big surprise i'm
going to make hazelnut soup for dinner surprise
there's something i want to tell
you oh rapunzel you know i hate
leaving you after a fight especially
when i've done absolutely nothing wrong
you are not leaving this tower
ever the frying pan rapunzel
i know what i want for my birthday now and what
is that the paint made from the white shells you
once brought me you're sure you'll be all right
on your own i know i'm safe as long as i'm here
i've packed you six apples for three days worth
of a trip and a hunk of bread ration it out
i love her hair is like a superpower
who are you and how did you
find me i know not who you are
nor how i came to find you but may i just say hi
oh my man oh no where is my
satchel i've hidden it somewhere
you'll never find it it's in that pot isn't it
take me to these lanterns and return me home
safely and only then will i return your satchel to
you just enough time to fall in love this is kind
of an off day for me this doesn't normally happen
fine i'll take you to see the lanterns
really ah oops it's okay it worked on
me that was an innuendo you think she'd
be more subject to the smolder i know i
mean having literally no suitors for 18 years
look at it all so big do i even dare here i go
if i take one step further further
from the shire that i've ever featured
and finally
you're getting your hair so dirty right now
got to be so many bugs and twigs
in there i can't believe i did that
mother would be so furious that's okay i mean what
she doesn't know won't kill her right oh my gosh
i am a horrible daughter i'm
would this break her heart and crush your
soul of course but you've just got to do it
that is that's growing up
another different
nose yeah hide the nose the faces on this horse
a palace horse where's your
rider rapunzel rapunzel oh shoot
rapunzel
oh no
god rapunzel you suck at hiding stuff
ah there it is the snuggly duckling
your finest table please
you don't look so good blondie maybe we should get
you home call it a day this is a five-star joint
after all and if you can't handle this place
well maybe you should be back in your tower
what was this you oh now they're just
being mean oh it's him all right i'm broke
get back we can work this out
oh not the nose not the nose not the nose
i'm i'm malicious mean and scary despite my
evil look and my temper and my hook i've always
yearned to be a concert pianist yep i'd rather
be called deadly for my killer show tuned medley
that voice is the one that's bothering me i
probably garrett's killer souls little puppy
and vladimir collects ceramic unicorns
live your best life lad
just want to see these lanterns every passing
hour i'm so glad i left my tower oh no
where's ryder where is he backstabbington brothers
go live your dream i will your
dream stinks i was talking to her
thanks for everything
oh this dream came true this
is the man you're looking for
you got me sir there's no sign of ryder
maximus
you play for the wrong team maximus
a passage come on man let's go that horse is
as smart as an elephant we'll go get the crown
way to go fred and george
who's that they don't like me here
such a swashbuckling vibe
oh mama i have got to get me one of these
you should know that this is the
strangest thing i've ever done
that horse is relentless
cool do it legolas
wow
that horse is gonna be surfing
gotta save the pan
you're awfully reliant on that pan
without the pen they'd be dead already
it's no use i can't see anything
hey there's no point it's pitch black down
there sing the song i'm so sorry flynn
eugene
what my real name is eugene fitzherbert gesente
i have magic when i sing i
didn't even think about it
how's the glow lasting for so long great question
maybe she's singing in her head her hair glows
we're live i'm alive i didn't see that coming
eugene they're actually glows eugene
why does her hair glow eugene what
perhaps you want to stop acting like wild
dogs and think for a moment i was going
to offer you something worth 1000 crowns enjoy
your crown well now they're gonna want to know
you set them up to ask that once
that's right yeah man she doesn't
realize what she's singing about
she can get her parents back now mother says
when i was a baby people tried to cut it
once it's cut it turns brown and loses
its power that's why i never left and
you never left that tower but the gift's
not even being used a book i used to read
every night to all the younger kids the tales
of flenigan ryder you can't tell anyone about
this it could ruin my whole reputation [__] i
i should i should get some more firewood for the
record i like eugene fitzherbert much better than
flynn rider then you'd be the first but thank you
i like the name ryder better but if he could
have the personality of eugene that would be
the best i thought he'd never leave mother hello
dear how did you find me oh it was easy really
i just listened for the sound of complete
and utter betrayal and followed that
i think he likes me likes you please rapunzel
that's demented what's to like look at you you'll
think that he's impressed don't be a dummy come
with mummy mother no mother no no go ahead then
give him this trust me my dear that's how
fast you leave go and put him to the test
good luck oh
well i hope you're here to apologize
easy
now sit sit what now drop
the boot i serve off camera
are you all tired from chasing
this bad man all over the place
excuse me nobody appreciates you do
they do they oh come on he's a bad horse
oh he's nothing but a big he's like the greatest
horses ever horse efforts i need you not
to get him arrested just for 24 hours and then you
can chase each other to your heart's content okay
oh yeah kill a man easily probably ruptured
a few of his internal organs doing that
wow that is economical
i didn't look like the average
white girl i think that was me
never about to dance
you go enjoy your time with that woman
fun we've been dancing for three hours
it took this long to get together hey max
what i bought them
with my hands
where are we going well the best day of your life
now you're an accomplice too
you should have a decent seat
hogwarts you okay i've been looking out a
window for 18 years dreaming about what i
might feel like when those lights rise in the sky
what if it's not everything i dreamed it would be
it will be and what if it is you get
a hat you just chase that high forever
cool
light your own beacon home i have something for
you too i should have given it to you before but
i was just scared i'm not scared anymore you
know what i mean you steal whatever stuff you
want oh he didn't even grab it all those years
living in a blur all that time never truly seeing
thing now she's here shining in the
sun wow what a beautiful shot damn is
is everything okay huh oh
yes uh yes of course i just
gotta get paid man everything is fine
there's just something i have to take care of
okay oh you got a guilty walk my guy
the crown is all yours i'll miss you
but i think it's for the best we heard you
found something something oh we want her
instead i was starting to think you
ran off with the crown and left me
wow they walk in a great line like
we're gonna use the fog to our advantage
how much do you think someone would pay to
stay young and healthy forever no please no no
the one time it gets caught in something
rapunzel mother are you all right are you hurt
how did you i was so worried about you dear
so i followed you oh my let's go let's go
before they come to is he like tied to it or
something he's got to be it's either like a
dummy or else he's yeah just like knocked
out and tied to it look the crown rapunzel
no no no wait wait wait guys
come on max change of heart
fly max fly unlock your inner pegasus
let's get this over with ryder where are we
going community service now wash up for dinner
i'm making hazelnut soup i really did try rapunzel
i tried to warn you what was out there all true
my mother kidnapped me when i was a baby
i subconsciously painted the whole story
uncovered memory rapunzel
rapunzel what's going on up there yeah
i'm making a hair gun close the door mom
let's take a seat i am the lost princess aren't
i did i mumble no mother did i stutter [__]
do you even hear yourself why would you ask such
a ridiculous question it was you it was all you
everything i did was to protect you
what did you do to him that criminal
is to be hanged for his crimes for stealing
all those apples all of this is as it should be
no you were wrong about the world break her
wrists and i will never let you use my hair again
what's this open up one
two
three
hey use the frying pan gotta get
me a good frying pan head down
head down arms in arms in knees apart knees
why why do i need to keep my knees apart
oh my god oh my god your genitals would
be smashed crushed into a fine powder
dude i gotta get me a maximus
oh my god it'd be great to own a horse like max
strategist this is your whole army
right there rapunzel let down your hair
oh my god he got stabbed he
got real stabbed for real
oh look what you've done rapunzel we are
going where no one will ever find you again
now you've crossed the line pascal i won't stop
for every minute of the rest of my life i will
fight i will never stop trying to get away from
you if you let me save him i will go with you no
no rapunzel i'll never run oh for por though just
let me heal him and you and i will be together
forever just like you want everything will be the
way it was i'll be your battery mom i'm so sorry
everything is gonna be okay no rapunzel i promise
you have to trust me no come on rapunzel wait oh
oh
what have you done what have
you done yikes oh bad news
i like the symbolism
that lizard murdered her yep look
at me look at me i'm right here
don't go stay with me eugene flower gleam and
glow let you power shine make the clock reverse
bring back what once was rapunzel dude why don't
you just let her save you first then cut her
wow we need to experiment on you rapunzel
repository what is your dna made yeah what can
the rest of your bodily faculties do one teardrop
did i ever tell you i've got a thing for brunettes
i hate your natural haircut you are
very ugly to me until this moment
all thanks to maximus maximus mvp
i'm so happy
you get in here buddy you're
part of the family too
the kingdom rejoiced for the lost princess
had returned they pardoned me for all my
fever thanks to maximus crime in the
kingdom disappeared almost overnight
as a general at last rapunzel was home and she
finally had a real family well i'm pleased to
tell you that after years and years of asking
and asking and asking i finally said yes
and we're living happily ever after yes we are
oh my god he was cupid all along dang twist
all right guys well before we go into this a
word from storyblocks thank you to storyblocks
for sponsoring this video being the cinematic
artisans we obviously are we are always in
search of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap is good
and if you're a content creator or filmmaker or
anything in between you're probably in a similar
position it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking the
bank or burning yourself out in the process
which is why i heavily encourage you guys to check
out what storyblocks has to offer cheap is good do
you feel like this is their way of telling us that
the videos could be looking better yes whether
it's the credibility of an exotic establishing
shot the soothing comfort of the perfect music
bed or just the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an incredibly
inclusive and diverse library of faces places
sounds titles transitions filters and effects
and more over a million assets royalty free
and available for personal and commercial use
with your membership sounds so affordable this is
quite affordable they have multiple subscription
levels to suit your exact needs whether you're
an independent indie solo creator or a whole team
so if you want to learn more head on down to
our link in the description box and get started
that's at storyblocks.com rejects now back to
the video all right john this is actually my
fifth time watching this one oh no knew it
beat by beat um what did you think that was
lovely i've heard often this movie held up as
one of the best of the you know recent revival
of disney animated musicals and whatnot and uh
i got swept up and was quite delighted i mean
these are i it always like catches me and it
takes me a second to orient because like they
they tend to like get off on the story in a
way where i'm like oh we're already doing this
um but yeah like as it uh unfolds and as
it goes i thought it was quite charming
and i don't know the rapunzel story like the
back of my hand i know like the very basics
um so yeah it was it was cool to sort of be in
this place where i'm like okay i can kind of see
i think where they're kind of embellishing and
turning this into more of a disney fairy tale
but uh but yeah i thought it was really
charming and delightful i like the voice
cast you know yeah manny moore and hugh jackman
that's right man you nailed it for everyone
listening to the podcast john hugh jackman thought
it was an american accented jackman this american
accent throws me a microphone put it in put it
inside your mouth scraping against your beard
there we go there you go yeah hugh jackman's
american accent throws me sometimes
but uh zachary levi props to him and i wouldn't
have guessed i wouldn't have guessed for a movie
like this um but yeah it was quite charming
there's a lot of really lovely little visual
flourishes and i guess one thing i kept noticing
was it's it's fascinating to me how far the
animation has come because there are absolutely
aspects of this movie that are beautiful and
gorgeous to behold even for the time because
there are certain things that have certainly
gotten better i feel like rock textures now are
insane by comparison but they still have such a
grip on color and uh and light especially
like with all those lanterns and all that
like foliage with the shadows and sun bright sun
shining through illuminating all this greenery
illumination elimination uh yeah i i thought
uh from an animation perspective it was quite
lovely to behold and uh it's it's uh i the mom is
it's an interesting experience because i'm like
you're supposed she's supposed
to get on your nerves and she is
in many ways the villain and i thought it was
interesting the way that they orchestrated that
uh because she actually did get on my nerves but
not in a way that annoyed me in spite of the movie
what do you mean i just want to strangle her the
whole time just let her know even when she's being
sweet i'm like oh you're frustrating oh really i
enjoyed her so much i let no i really liked the
performance i i really liked the mannerisms
they animated her with and the actress's
uh performance in there but also i was like
uh like i'm not and i like it's weird i'm
not holding it against the movie because i don't
think it's asking you to be like nah she's good
you know uh no i set her up as the villain right
from the beginning but yeah but but you know like
seeing through rapunzel's perspective early on
before she knows like i feel like you could play
that character in a way where she is deceptively
sweet in a way that in the moment you could see
how rapunzel could endear to her where you know
uh i don't think they did that so much here
uh well i do think that they'd i
would i would vehemently disagree
okay strongly almost aggressively disagree
okay i want to strangle you instead of her
i mean she was raised from birth though yeah
it's not like no i get came into her oh my
god fine i can't get a word in this [__] review
sorry kids children came here sorry guys i'll uh
um i'm sorry what were you saying no it all
made sense like yeah because rapunzel's been
raised by her so of course she's not
gonna have any reason to suspect uh
the mannerisms being indicators of the fact that
she's not actually a benevolent caring mother
they just read his quirks to her because of course
that's all she knows then why are you questioning
it it was just an interesting flavor i wasn't
expecting what were you expecting something really
dark and heavy no something where like the mom is
like really cloying and like overly like lovely
until we get the you know aside moments where
she's on her own and then it's like haha i'm my
evil motivations blah blah blah where uh i don't
know they they kind of struck an interesting
nuance that i just wasn't well they can't make
her likeable i know this is not a complaint it
would be very difficult to make you know
harder i don't want them to make her like
if the kids were watching this in the theaters and
they were like i like her though she's sweet mommy
and she's been sweet up until the last 10 minutes
of this movie oh my god that would be so harsh
yeah i'm not just participating they got to
make her unlikable throughout sure john please
stop fighting yes yes of course
sorry i'll let it i'll let this go
this is embarrassing you're so defensive over
nothing that's right i'll let i'll loosen up
please in all cases oh yeah she was my she was my
hero the mom i was like i could learn a lot from
her because if you can control your kids like
that you have less less annoying [__] going
on in movie theaters you know what i mean that's
right just sit there and be like damn why'd you
bring your kid to this movie oh shut up they're
not interested in being you can kill your kid
yes tilt them into being obedient submissive
guilt them or scare them yeah uh yeah i i was
surprised by it's because it's a 2010 movie and
i forget how much movies have changed yeah you
reminded me of the period of when this came out
because this movie is mainly like a it's very i
guess that's the thing what surprised me the most
is how remarkably straightforward it is yeah it's
it's unbelievably straightforward in its execution
and uh yeah it it there's it's almost like
like so it's so simple in the way they go
about it yeah and it's just about enjoying the
experience i think what helps elevate it
is the personalities of the characters
that's the most refreshing aspect to it because
in terms of like how this movie goes down it is
so straightforward and there's like no fat around
anything no no no not at all it's very lean and
um was this before frozen i want to say i imagine
it is because i feel like this ushered in the
the revamp of the big disney musical experience
like it didn't disappear but i feel like this
was definitely like the harbinger of a new sort
of renaissance that would then get away from
because my experience has been kind of all over
the place then with the disney animated stuff
you know yeah if this is the first so yeah
it's very straightforward film and that's not a
it's not a bad thing and it's it's just like oh
i you know this movie is so praised and so loved
that i was expecting something a little bit more
perhaps nuance throughout or something but i was
like oh this is really just a enjoyable film yeah
it's like it's really economical and compact and i
was thinking about this during the movie because
there are there are disney movies in this vein
that do strike me that way where i'm like okay
this this had to be kind of like probably the most
compact version of the events and script
possible partly because i'm sure there's
a lot more and different coordination dealing
with the animation and music and whatnot but
even the like like it has a few songs that's
the other thing too is i was i was taken aback
by how straightforward because like once you're
20 or so minutes in you're like oh no like we're
well into the actual plot not just like setting up
things uh but also you know like there are a few
songs that are placed and for some reason it felt
like there were maybe less songs than like your
true the disney musical you would expect but uh
and at times it feels like the songs are not even
like the complete track yeah yeah it's interesting
it's a musical but in a in a way that felt
a little bit slightly different and i've often
heard people say when talking about the various
disney musicals of late that this is one of their
favorites in terms of memorable songs i really
love the mother song about mother knows best i
think that's really strong yeah it was very catchy
and um you know of course you got mandy moore
on there so i imagine that was really her scene
has to be a crime that would be to rob we're gonna
get somebody just got her to do the the acting but
not the singing yeah um i was like it's exactly
revising but the personalities of the characters i
i thought were just so charming and and so likable
and i was really endeared to the main duo of
eugene and rapunzel i was i found them really
endearing and it got really sweet and touching
like very very heartfelt in the last few moments
as well uh and i'm a little bit more used to the
storytelling of today of things that are
like they go for like the deeper messages
or something more nuanced to tell the kids
and and here it it didn't really do like
what's the message this will cut your
hair oh good question don't don't listen
to your overbearing mother if she's evil if it
turns out she's evil maybe don't listen to her
find find your own path in life
don't don't let people keep going
don't steal and uh don't steal look for
love find love like it's it's really like
just a kind of a classic disney story but with
a modern day with a complete modern day overhaul
is is what it feel what it ultimately felt
like i guess there's that aspect of because
when when the hair is cut and she's like oh no
you know i don't have any i'm not special anymore
but then this is the special was within her all
along i think that's probably the yeah the message
is uh it's not you don't need your
special hair to be a unique and
beautiful uh soul yeah it's okay to cry it's
okay to cry it heals wounds like all the pokemon
at the end of pokemon the movie hey man save ash
save ash tears that bring people back to life
all it took was one i like the way they did that
that struck me i haven't noticed something like
that like that at least comes to mind in an
animated movie lately where it's like that
whole death scene has this really washed out
color that contrasts the you know from the
rest of the entire movie which i thought was
a cool choice yeah and uh yeah black and white
well almost it's like as desaturated as you can
be with while still having color and then the mom
just you know whizzing in in front of your very
eyes i guess i guess i found myself the the flavor
of like the last 10 minutes is kind of what i
was hoping was sprinkled in a little bit more
throughout i did find myself craving a little
bit of that because yeah this is before the
time that they seem to go out of their like
i remember the like frozen then frozen too
yeah like frozen two has this sort of
interestingly shaped plot that isn't very
straightforward and frozen one had the you know
buzz of being really subversive in terms of their
formula and so i feel like here you're you're pre
that yeah so this is like yeah this is like them
doing the classic but in a in the most modern
at the time you know means possible yeah yeah
yeah and i appreciate that but yeah it was that
sort of thing where at first because because yeah
everybody holds it up as like nah man that one's
great i'm like okay there's got to be something
like wildly unique about it's the reputation
walking into it yeah that set kind of this
precedent in our mind of here's i'm expecting
like that level of emotional impact yeah yeah
yeah but but in a lot of ways like you know
like i don't want to be insulting to anyone
well because it's not because i know how much
this movie means to people so that's why i'm
semi mincing my words here is because of the
fact that i know this movie is so near and
dear to people and it's not really a fear of
being honest it's a fear of offending without
uh wanting to yeah so i'm just intentionally
don't get it twisted i'm not disappointed and
i didn't dislike it i'm just i you know when
people hail something i feel like it creates
i don't know any expectation of greatness is
always going to kind of inspire a different
uh thing in each viewer so yeah it takes a little
to orient yourself to but at the end i wasn't like
i don't know what anyone's talking about you know
yeah i mean i liked it and i thought it was very
charming and and very enjoyable entertaining
but i i can't say i i love this movie yeah
yeah i'm glad that i'm glad i saw it i would
happily watch it again i think i'll think the
most about maximus the horse yeah oh he was great
i thought the life they brought to maximus was
i mean they have that classic disney thing
where turn them into a dog at one point
like a dog pretty much that's what they do with
all these to even dreamworks any animated property
does it doggify hey thor's hammer is a dog now
dog or cat he is a dog or catted that's the way
you make a an animal relatable this is make
it like everyone's most common domestic pets
and they did at one point but when they weren't
doing that i was actually really um i was really
satisfied with the way how much they made maximum
super expressive and instead of just riding the
line of him being you know a horse that's a little
bit more expressive than your average horse they
just want to full extreme with him and then he was
like soldier and a general and i really and like
i love that at the end he was like training and
so i think that was really funny mm-hmm well it's
too a dis an example of one of these movies that
ha you have pascal and you have maximus but there
aren't a whole lot of other like you know there's
not the classic montage of like oh the woodland
creatures are helping me spruce up the tower
you know like it's it seems like they are the
two creatures who are given yeah anthropomorphic
abilities to the utmost degree and then pretty
much all the other animals seem normal but i would
like a really dark twisted version of the story
one that would ruin the lives of everyone i i
think that would be very enjoyable yeah instead
of tangled call it twisted twisted twisted i like
it i like it a lot mother going super dark really
manipulative locker and you should be like carrie
yes oh my god you could do it though that's the
problem is that's actually a decent picture i'm
sure the if this mother is in the real rapunzel
story making what it is like just make it a
full-blown horror movie and maybe about trauma
that she kills her mom because i'm like yeah you
know i i feel like uh uh uh if they made this
movie today i'm not saying they would go all adult
but i think they might have pushed it a bit more
especially in terms of the central conflict uh
because i thought that's what they were setting up
like i do love you mom and i like every day i do
love you um it's it's not like cinderella being
you know forced into this stepdaughter situation
you know everyone's just terrible yeah yeah or
it's like yes you'll get away and she's not going
to miss you honestly i feel like cinderella had a
word since like like cinderella didn't have it
worse but but uh though her emotional response
to her mom and and where she lives is so much
worse like that is like overbearing and so
that feels like this is abusive yeah yeah and and
they don't do that here with rapunzel yeah and
and i and i so i was thinking that they might go
the route towards the end when she does find out
the truth of feeling more conflicted yeah about it
because i'm like this is my mom this is the woman
who raised me but it was like once she realized
it it it was like no you're bad i gotta get out
yeah this fight that we just started
having well that's everything now
this just goes to support my my rebellion and
so i thought there might have been a bit more
of a layered conflict there and and i thought
the movie was building oh i thought the movie
was actually setting that up yeah yeah cause
there's a lot you can there's or even with the
evil mom you know like actually learning to love
her and stuff yeah like or or maybe some kind
of conflict yeah of like i i have bonded i mean
you know i've raised you for eight 17-ish years
now and uh even though i guess you yeah you could
pitch it as more of a s uh sympathetic symbiosis
where it's like yeah i need her but maybe i'm
gonna bargain with myself and tell myself that
maybe this isn't messed up in some kind of way uh
yeah i think it's because disney movies nowadays
i i feel like they're not afraid to kind of
explore like pain or some trauma loss you know
you know um right now parents got right now they
seem like they're obsessed with generational drama
yeah and and i and and i think that was the thing
about this movie it seemed like that's they wanted
to make sure they stayed so far away from that
she is evil she is the [__] and every time
she's like ever so lighthearted and when she
finds out the truth there's no questions asked
anytime she's alone she's going
to remind us that she's evil
and uh it's like the parents her biological
parents the king and queen they they
you know they check in with them and i like kind
of the quiet melancholy uh like the somber tone
with them like they don't really talk you just
see them looking sad and uh so i like the way they
were captured and um yeah it seemed like they were
like going darker and and i and i did expect that
because i thought the movie was setting
up but i'm like now i'm questioning
it's because of how they they're they're
willing to do that a little bit more now
nowadays they're willing to do that a little bit
more so is that why i was expecting it to happen
here now but what i've expected the same thing
back 12 years ago yeah that's a great question
i would be very curious i mean because two because
they evolved their movies now to so that because
because the fact they weren't doing it back
then yeah and and it makes you wonder because i
you know i sit here and go okay they
probably made these choices because
i don't want to talk down but it feels like a more
like yeah it's super safe yeah kids family movie
choice we got to make it really clear who the good
guys and the bad guys are so that i mean it's like
we would like these nuances and things and there's
a lot of interesting territory to explore there
although you know for a young audience maybe
those things are a little more confusing or
a little more you know maybe uh prone to flying
over people's heads or something children's heads
um so i get that they i don't know it seems
like maybe they wanted to keep those things
clear and have since let go of those yeah um you
know because like you know like a frozen has that
whole thing where it's like you got the prince
and you you you're the whole time being sold to
think he's pretty great and then it turns out oh
dang he's not you know and uh i mean i don't think
that would be hard for kids to process but it is a
bit of a different thing you know more of a nuance
true but still as a movie directly aim for
children um it's solid entertainment yeah
and um yeah i can see how especially for the
time it came out and of why it's stood the
test of time because was this too i almost feel
like this i don't know the history of disney uh
you know completely but i feel like they've
had definitely ebbs and flows in the perceived
quality and popularity of their different uh
especially like musicals and princess movies and
flagships and stuff like that i feel like when
they start tapping into the computer animation
is when they were like we're going super late
is this yeah and and is this one of the cause
because i'm trying to think of when this came out
in relation to princess and the frog because that
was the last time they did like a hand-drawn
animated musical and i feel like that was like
the mid-2000s or something and then this almost if
i'm not mistaken maybe that sort of kick off into
i think meet the robinsons was the kickoff oh
okay sure meet the robinsons it was one of the
earlier ones and people forget about that one is
that a muse does their music it's not musical but
it is a it is like like is that pixar no it's
just disney yeah disney animation yeah and then
you go one step further with a movie like this
and you go cause this is yeah it's like it's
it's princess movie it's princess musical
it's it's like animated disney flagship
you know type of story and i feel like this kicked
that back off in the cg realm yeah so maybe two
people have that uh intense love because it is
kind of the beginning of a new phase or a new
era age yeah some kind of precious metal age
totes mcgoats yeah you know you know it's
a delightful disney doing their their thing
well guys here we are here we are what'd
you guys think about tangled leave your
thoughts down below but before we wrap this
video up let's do a patron of the day show
my god it's got to be lance door who else would
you want to get tangled up with right oh my
goodness who's the person when you're caught at
the top of a building or a tower who's going to go
up there to rescue you you want to see a little
lance door at the land store getting that fire
truck up there with that extended ladder yeah you
climbing his way up there climb my hair lance door
uh i was just doing a straightforward fire fire
bit but you're a firefighter yeah you're
saying you're gonna let that firefighter
i don't know if you want a firefighter to
climb your you'd have to bring climb the ladder
you gotta bring a whole bunch of
[__] it's like a lot of extra pounds
oh yeah you got so much gear and i i regret
this immediately oh lance don't take the ladder
like he was saying i was saying just i was just
doing the scenario being caught up in a tower and
someone's gonna rescue me yeah and it should be
lance i'm with you me putting my hair down and
yeah that's fair i i was more trying to meet
you part way like oh what if the ladder's not
tall enough to get to the top of the tower so i
got to like bridge the rest of the gap with my
was your hair with your hair yeah and he would
help so and then your hair me out of the tower
under the weight of all of his gear plus the
strength as compared to probably gwen stacy you
by accident he would absolutely like be like
i'll pull you out and then you pull me out
my head would probably just come clean
off and then my body would just plummet
to the ground oh there's a horror movie
what if it like attaches to the ladder
and then he starts pulling you away and and
then lance accidentally removes your scalp
oh yeah oh you know i could come back from that
at least do you die from a scalping if you just
get a i think it's very likely you're going to if
you could get some disinfectant on there and just
seal that wound up real quick you know put put
yourself a gauze hat you know would you be okay
lance if you have any experience
with scalping this is really dark
if any of you kids stuck around for this
lighthearted shout out oh my god they've all
heard some swear words before but yeah this was
swear for free i don't know the shoutouts were
free shout out to the discussion is swear free
but if they got this far and now we've introduced
the concept of removing a person's content
it's just got some thematic elements and some
references to violence rated pg-13 hey there was
a little blood in this movie yeah for like samus
thanks lance love you buddy you